hello everyone as you seem to have
enjoyed my yesterday's videos about
vastly unchoke I decided to show you one
more game played by this genius and well
if I have already won three linearis
titles and this game was played in 1996
I was the 58th annual humans tournament
in the vibrancy Netherlands and
eventually won the 1st place it was a
clear win the tournament featured 14 of
the strongest players in the world event
took one one full point ahead of this
one at an island and one and a half
point I had a third place vessel into
polyp and this is considered to be one
of the greatest games ever played and it
features a one move that is by some
consider to be the the greatest move
ever played so let's see this game Oh
India and even Chuck was undefeated for
the entire tournament event shook his
white and he is playing Alexey Shirov I
would have d4 d5 c4 we have c6 the Slav
and Knight to c3 Knight to f6 Knight to
f3 d6 we have Bishop to g5 d captures on
c4 and we have E for the bottom in ik
variation which is one of the sharpest
would have b5 we have E 5 and well now
it seems that sure of is losing a piece
but he's really not he plays h6
attacking the bishop we have a Bishop to
h4 and now g5 attacking the bishop one
more time so now the night isn't pinned
anymore and we have Knight captures and
G file a temporary peace sacrifice H
captures and g5 and Bishop captures and
g5 and okay the night is still pinned
and a magic will recapture his piece
sure place might be to d7 and we have in
captures on f6 and Bishop to b7
it's the sure of is playing Bishop to d7
to assume this beautiful diagonal for
his light squared bishop we have g3 by
vine choked and sure pushes c5 and this
is it seems like a good move it's
preparing to to capture this d4 pawn and
also he has a discovered attack on this
rook on h1 so there's only one more one
way to stop both red
you want to place d5 we have Queen to b6
and Bishop to g2 queenside castle and
the kingside castle by von Schuch
all we have before attacking this knight
on c3 eventual place at Knight to a4 we
have Queen to b5 and we have a three and
well Avantika of course wants to open
this a file for his roof so he can
attack this a 7-point and get some play
on the Queen side but this allows each
capture Sun d5 we have a capture some b4
and the C capture some before and okay
now we want you guys have this open file
for his rook and here in fine Chuck
comes up with such a brilliant
masterpiece plan this is this is insane
he plays Bishop to e3 and with this move
he is attacking this a 7-point and okay
this is easily defended sure plays
Knight to c5 and well he doesn't really
mind after the Knight captures that this
Rock will be targeting a7 as if if
Knight captures Bishop captures and
everything is what the a7 pawn is
defended
but here comes he want troops a
brilliant idea he plays a queen to g4
with check and well black does have a
couple of moves to consider here
definitely he doesn't want to play
something like King to c7 as he will
this will be met with the bishop to f4
check and the black king is coming down
the board so after Queen to g4 he can
consider something like King to b8 but
this would actually run into Queen to d4
and this is attacking this Knight three
times and if the knight moves the world
and this a seven pawn is going down with
check for example if Knight captures the
Queen captures on a7 would check and
after King to c7 rook captures on a4 and
this is winning for white so after King
to g4 the best move for sure of here was
actually to play Queen to d7 and block
the check this way but this is some
somewhat counterintuitive as this leaves
this Knight and c5 unprotected as it's
already attacked twice so should have
tried a different idea he tried rock to
d7 and well this is now
the main punishing line event you
prepared
he plays Queen to g7 and this is a
wonderful move this is so so crushing
what's the idea behind the Queen to g7
well obviously he's attacking this rook
on h8 the rook can't really be defended
but the bishop of course can capture the
Queen but the whole idea is that this
bishop is actually protecting the c5
Knight and the bishop can't capture the
Queen and still protect the c5 Knight so
sure of capture the Queen we have Bishop
captures on g7 and F captures and g7
wouldn't attack on the rock on h8 so
this has to be protected rook to g8 and
now if I plays Knight captures on c5 and
now he's attacking this rock and a7 also
the bishop on b7 which could be well
kind of kind of bad for black as this
Bishop is already on g2 the rook is
attacking an a7 and what black has to
come up with a move probably best would
be to simply move this rook from from b7
and get him out of harm's away but she
replaced d4 he's attacking this bishop
here and also creating a very powerful
pawn Center and okay this does open up
this bishop diagonal so you might want
to capture that bishop characters
ambition would check we have rock
captures an b7 and Knight captures an b7
and sure does not recapture the night
just yet
he plays Queen to b6 he would much
rather capture this Bishop on e3 and if
if I took stops this then he will come
to capture the night but if I don't
replace Bishop captures on before
attacking the Queen now we have Queen
captures on d4 and we have rooked F to D
one with an attack on the Queen
sure plays Queen capture some b2 we have
Knight to d6 with check King to be 8 and
now rook D to be 1 now with an attack on
the Queen and also on the b4 pawn after
the Queen moves we have Queen captures
on g7
finally getting rid of that annoying for
rope capture some before would check we
have King to c7 and now rook to a6
and this is with a very very powerful
threat of rook to b7 check also with a
threatened on f7 so sure stops this he
plays rook to b8 but this allows Avenger
to play rock captures on a 7 with check
and there is no way for sure of the
defend this rook anymore he plays King
captures on d6 we have rook capture some
b8 we have Queen to g4 look of course
checks on d8 we have King to c6 and now
rook to a 1 not allowing any Queen d1
ideas and well after this rook to a one
move sure of resigned the game as he
does have this pasty pawn but there is
no way to take advantage of this as if
the Queen ever moves from defending c8
simply wrote the ch-check picks it up
and if Sherwood try to maybe attack the
rook then simply rope the d2 and there
is no way to stop white from from
playing something like rook to c1 and
then simply doubling up on the C file
and the white wall white will give up
both rooks for the Queen and then simply
and easily want to end game with 3
points to 1 so yeah but in this position
have two looked a1 sure resigned and you
want to own this brilliant game and like
I said we want the entire tournament he
was undefeated 5 wins and it draws no no
losses so yeah definitely a quite an
achievement for the genius he von Schuch
so yeah that's it for this game I would
like to thank Tony more what neeraja
Kashyap and John Collier for a
contribution to my channel thank you
very much I really appreciate it and as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I'll see you soon